Welcome to the debate.
America is wrestling with
fractures so deep they threaten
the very idea of shared
understanding, maybe even shared
reality itself.
Today we confront this profound
challenge through the lens of a
singular violent event, the
assassination of Charlie Kirk.
As detailed in the source
material Aftershocks PDF.
This isn't just a political
incident, it's really a
flashpoint that exposes some
fundamental societal fissures.
Our central question for this
discussion is stark.
Does Charlie Kirk's
assassination reveal in America
fundamentally fractured into,
well, two nations fighting
entirely incompatible wars with
no shared understanding?
Or do these differing
interpretations of foundational
concepts like martyrdom and sin,
do they still operate within a
broadly recognizable human
framework, offering perhaps a
difficult but potential path for
understanding across these
divides?
I will argue for the profound
and nearly irreconcilable
incompatibility of these
worldviews, contending that the
sides don't even share the same
battlefield and.
I'll be presenting the
perspective that despite these
vast differences in
interpretation, shared human
frameworks from meaning making
do persist, allowing for, well,
at least a degree of
translatability across these
deep cultural chasms.
OK, so the assassination of
Charlie Kirk and the aftershocks
that followed, they powerfully
demonstrate that America is
engaged in what the source
material calls 2 wars.
Here, the left and the right
seem to operate with
fundamentally different
understandings of reality, of
language, and even of what
constitutes meaning itself.
This isn't just about, you know,
political disagreement.
It feels like a breakdown in
shared discourse, making common
ground seem increasingly
elusive.
The source explicitly states
that two sides aren't fighting
the same battle.
They don't even share the same
battlefield.
Now, what this implies is a
fundamental divergent in the
very definition of conflict
itself.
At the core of this fracture are
what's Aftershocks PDF
identifies as the two languages
of war.
The left often employs a
materialist vocabulary, focusing
on power dynamics, oligarchs,
systemic oppression, identity
politics, even treating words as
violence.
This stands in stark contrast to
the Wrights spiritual language,
which is centered on figures
like demons, Satan, and an
unseen enemy with a capital E
believing in what they call
warfare in the heavens.
These aren't just different
opinions, they represent
distinct ontological frameworks,
meaning they disagree on what
reality fundamentally is.
And you know how the world
operates.
This leads to what the material
aptly calls an unbearable
inversion of logic concerning
violence.
For the left, the mantra has
often been words or violence,
suggesting that misgendering or
hate speech can wound as deeply
as physical harm.
Yet when an actual bullet
pierces a man's throat, many
voices on the side while they
cheer, perceiving it as justice.
It's a profound paradox.
Words are violence, but actual
violence can be justice.
On the other hand, the rights
logic completely reverses.
Words are not violence, they are
truth telling, even if
uncomfortable.
But bullets in this framework
are never justice.
They are seen as leading to
martyrdom, proof of spiritual
warfare.
The concept of martyrdom itself
vividly illustrates his fracture
to the secular left.
If Kirk is called a martyr at
all, it's often sarcastic,
framing him as a demagogue whose
death weakens a movement to the
right.
His killing is martyrdom in the
oldest Christian sense, a
witness to truth, slain by the
world's hatred.
These aren't just different
shades of meaning, they are
entirely distinct worldviews,
clashing in their fundamental
interpretations of life, death
and purpose.
I I come at this from a slightly
different perspective.
While Aftershocks PDF undeniably
illustrates profound discord and
radically differing
interpretations in America,
framing these as entirely
incompatible worldviews that
share no common ground, well
that might overstate the actual
divide.
My reading of the material
suggests that fundamental human
experiences and these attempts
to find meaning, however
divergent their ultimate
conclusions might be, still
operate within broadly
recognizable frameworks.
While I absolutely acknowledge
the profound clash of
vocabularies you've highlighted,
the source itself carefully
defines martyrdom across
Christian, Islamic, and even
revolutionary materialist
contexts.
Now, this very active definition
and comparison, I think,
suggests a shared human impulse
to ascribe significance and
meaning to death for a 'cause
even if the paradise or the
afterlife differs wildly, the
phenomenon of sacrificial death
and the human need to view it
with meaning seem quite
universal.
These are perhaps different
worlds interpreting the same
underlying human drive.
Consider the word Sinner.
OK, to many Christians, it's a
baseline diagnosis, a
recognition of inherent human
failing in need of grace.
To many outsiders, though,
especially those may be burned
by strict religious upbringings,
it sounds like annihilation or a
crushing judgment.
However, both reactions are
responses to a core concept of
moral failing or transgression.
The dissonance lies in the
interpretation and implications.
You know, whether it's a pact to
redemption or a source of
trauma, not necessarily the non
existence of a shared moral
arena.
The trauma and rage section of
the document further supports
this.
It indicates that secular people
react strongly to terms like
sin, hell, and damnation, not
because these words are alien to
them, but precisely because they
trigger old wounds from, say,
childhood sermons and parental
discipline.
This points to a shared
historical and emotional
exposure to these concepts, even
if that experience leads to
rejection and pain.
Ultimately, the source
identifies the snipers shot as
the quake and the subsequent
interpretations as aftershocks.
Both sides are reacting to the
same originating event, implying
A singular reality that
generates multiple, albeit
radically different,
interpretations.
That common starting point is
key, I think.
I see why you'd want to find
those threads of commonality, I
really do.
But my contention remains that
the 2 languages of war, the
materialist versus the
spiritual, are so deeply
divergent they create
fundamentally different
battlefields.
When the source says they don't
even use the same dictionary, I
don't think it's hyperbole.
For instance, that capital E, an
enemy for the right, isn't just
a metaphor for political
opponents, it's understood as a
literal reference to Satan and
demonic forces.
Now, this directly contrasts
with the left's framing of
violence is purely political,
historical, and entirely
material.
How can true communication, not
just disagreement, even occur
when the very foundational terms
of conflict, the very nature of
reality itself, are so
fundamentally incompatible?
This isn't just a matter of
semantics, A dispute over words.
It's about ontology, meaning a
fundamental disagreement on the
very nature of being and reality
that makes bridging the gap seem
almost impossible.
I certainly acknowledge the
profound linguistic chasm you've
highlighted and the enormous
challenge it presents to well to
genuine discourse.
Yet I believe the source itself
offers a vital counterpoint to
this idea of complete
incompatibility.
The material, through its
glossary for outsiders, actually
attempts to bridge this very gap
by carefully defining terms like
sin, grace, the enemy, spiritual
warfare, and words are violence.
The document is performing an
act of translation.
It facilitates an understanding
of how these different groups
interpret their world.
Even if one doesn't agree with
those interpretations, this very
act of explanation, designed for
those outside the framework,
suggests at least a potential
for deciphering the other's
language.
It indicates a shared human
capacity for semantic
understanding, even across
deeply divergent worldviews.
The fact that we can articulate
the differences implies some
shared capacity for
comprehension for at least
mapping out the others
conceptual landscape, wouldn't
you say?
Perhaps mapping it out, But that
capacity to define the terms
doesn't necessarily lead to
shared meaning or, crucially, a
common moral calculus.
It's truly unsettling, isn't it?
This unbearable inversion
described in the Source, where
words can be violence but an
actual bullet can be justice for
one side, while for the other
words are truth and a bullet is
martyrdom.
How does a society even begin to
deliberate when the very
definitions of harm and justice
are inverted like that on the
left?
You know, a microaggression can
be equated to physical violence,
yet the actual physical violence
of a bullet striking Charlie
Kirk is, for some, cheered as
justice.
It's a profound paradox.
Then, on the right, the logic
reverses completely.
Words are not violence, they are
truth telling, even if
uncomfortable.
But bullets are never justice.
They are martyrdom, proof of
spiritual warfare.
This isn't just a difference in
opinion, it's a complete
inversion of how harm, truth,
and legitimate action are
understood.
It seems to remove any common
moral calculus, any shared way
of weighing what's right or
wrong, what's a just outcome, or
even how to assess the
consequences of an event.
Where do we begin when the very
compasses seem to be pointing in
opposite directions?
I find that assertion that it
entirely removes common ground
difficult to fully accept.
My perspective is this.
While I acknowledge the stark
contrast and how violence is
perceived and the profound moral
paradox it presents, I think
both sides are, in their own
way, attempting to legitimize
action or interpret suffering
within their respective moral
frameworks.
Take the rage felt by Acts
evangelicals described in the
Source as a response to
perceived condemnation and
spiritual trauma, and then
consider the Wrights belief that
demons rage when exposed as
their worldview is challenged.
These are both powerful, quite
visceral responses to perceived
injustice or threat.
Now, while the definitions of
justice or threat are
diametrically opposed, the
common thread might be the
fundamental human drive for
justice, for meaning, or maybe
for protection from perceived
harm.
The intensity of the reaction
itself suggests a shared
emotional landscape, however
fragmented it might appear on
the surface.
Think about the sheer human
force behind those reactions.
Rage.
Pain.
A drive for justice, while the
language used to describe them
or the solutions envisioned are
starkly opposed.
The fundamental, almost primal
impulse to respond to perceived
injustice or threat.
That strikes me as a share of
human landscape, however
fractured.
That's an interesting point
about the shared emotional
landscape, though I might frame
its implications differently.
The Aftershocks PDF makes a,
well a compelling case for the
profound implications of
martyrdom in these distinct
frameworks, and how it really
solidifies this idea of two
wars.
Consider the Hydra of MAGA
analogy used in the source for
the right.
Kirk's death isn't a set back.
Instead it's seen as a
fertilization of the movement,
akin to Christian martyrdom
where, you know, kill Jesus and
the church expands.
This spiritual framing means the
movement by its very nature
cannot be defeated by purely
material means like killing a
leader or suppressing voices.
It fundamentally changes the
nature of political struggle
compared to movements that rely
on a single leader or a purely
material ideology.
To the right, this is framed as
warfare in the heavens, and
physical death is merely a
transition, not an end.
This spiritual dimension, I
think, makes the conflict truly
irreducible to a shared earthly
battlefield.
It's not just a different
strategy, it's almost an
entirely different playing
field.
That is a powerful analogy, the
idea of a movement strengthened
by sacrifice, like a hydra
growing new heads.
But here's where I see a shared
thread, maybe a functional 1.
The source observes that even
revolutionary materialism uses
martyrdom to quote water, the
tree of freedom, ensuring glory
in memory and fueling a 'cause.
This highlights that while
different heavens or after lives
are envisioned, the function of
such a death to inspire comrades
and perpetuate a movement can be
paralleled across these
seemingly disparate worldviews.
The deep division is certainly,
and why it inspires and what it
inspires, I grant you that.
But that it inspires, that seems
to indicate a shared fundamental
mechanism for human movements to
coalesce around sacrifice.
It suggests a kind of
translatability of the purpose
of martyrdom, even if the
details of its spiritual or
material outcome differ wildly.
The underlying human need to
give meaning to sacrifice feels
universal here.
While.
I agree the function of
martyrdom inspiring A cause
might show a common thread.
It kind of circles back to our
initial point on linguistic
incompatibility, doesn't it?
The meaning of that sacrifice
and the nature of the enemy are
still so radically different
because of those two languages
of war that the inspiration
itself fuels completely
divergent ends.
One side sees the death as an
act of spiritual warfare against
literal evil, the other is a
olitical act against systemic
injustice.
O The insiration might be shared
structurally, perhaps, but the
direction it oints towards is
fundamentally opposing, which
further fractures the idea of a
cohesive society.
The material, particularly these
aftershocks of Charlie Kirk's
assassination, vividly
illustrates how America is
wrestling with profoundly
disparate worldviews.
The Two Wars narrative
underscores a challenge not just
of political disagreement, but
of a well a fundamental
divergent in linguistic,
theological, and moral
understanding.
This suggests A deeply fractured
landscape where common ground is
increasingly elusive and maybe
the very foundations of shared
reality are eroding, leaving us
to confront a society perhaps
more fragmented than we fully
grasp.
I'm not convinced that
necessarily means common ground
is entirely elusive, though.
While the differences are indeed
profound and generate
significant societal tremors,
the analysis in Aftershocks PDF
itself, simply by carefully
detailing these different
interpretations across various
frameworks, offers a kind of
framework for understanding why
people interpret events so
differently.
It underscores the shared human
attempt to make sense of
violence, sacrifice, and moral
failing, even if the resulting
interpretations remain starkly
divided.
We are, at our core, perhaps
trying to understand the same
core human phenomena.
The document almost provides A
Rosetta Stone, however
incomplete, for comprehending
the different languages we used
to do so.
This insightful analysis of the
aftershocks and their ongoing
rumble beneath us certainly lays
bare a complex and unsettling
reality, leaving us to
contemplate the implications of
such deep divisions.
And the potential, or indeed the
lack thereof, for shared
understanding standing in
America.
There is certainly much more to
explore within this fascinating
material and the enduring
questions it raises about our
society.